كما اشر مشاهدينا الانتشار الواسع
لمراشدينا لمراسلين في الميدان يعطينا
صوره عن الاوضاع الحاليه وابدا من حيث
انتهت نجوان سمري في منطقه تل ابيب بهذه
المنطقه التي لا تبعد الى حوالي 60 كيلو
متر عن قطاع غزه بصوره اقرب لتل ابيب فنحن
نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه او ما بات يعرف بتل
ابيب الكبرى في هذه المنطقه شمالي قطاع
غزه شمالي غرب مدينه القدس نقترب اكثر من
هذه المنطقه منطقه تل ابيب الكبرى واللد
تحديدا وندخل الى هذه الصوره الاقرب التي
كانت عنوان هذا اليوم بعمليه عسكريه وصفت
بالنوعيه ادت الى مقتل اسرائيلي واصابه
عدد منهم ويبدو ان هذه العمليه ستدخل هذه
المواجهه في سياق مختلف تماما اذا تحدثنا
عن رحوبه فنحن نتحدث عن هذه النقطه التي
لا تبعد الا حوالي 45 كيلو متر فقط جنوبي
مدينه اللد جنوبي مدينه او محافظه او ما
يعرف تل ابيب الكبرى في هذه النقطه تحديدا
لماذا رحوبه مركز مهم في هذه اللحظه لاننا
نتحدث عن 45 كيلو متر فقط عن مدينه غزه او
عن قطاع غزه الذي يظهر في الصوره ونحن
نتحدث عن اقل من عشره الى 12 كيلو مترا
فقط عن مطار بن غوريون في مدينه اللد
بصوره اقرب لهذه الدائره التي نتحدث عنها
والتي تشاهدونها الان على الشاشه فنحن
نتحدث عن هذه الدائره هذه رحوبه التي
تعرضت اليوم لقصف وادى هذا القصف لمقتل
اسرائيل واصابه عدد منهم بجروح ولكن هذه
المدينه لا تبعد الا كما اشرنا حوالي 12
كم فقط عن مطار بن غوريون ما يمكن الاشاره
اليه بان من الممكن ان مطار بن غوريون كان
هو هدف هذه الضربه الصاروخيه النوعيه
نتحدث عن مسافه قريبه للغايه من مطار بن
غوريون وبطبيعه الحال لا نبعد كثيرا عن
وسط مدينه الابيب التي تعرضت احيائها
الجنوبيه كما نشاهد على الشاشه ريشار كما
اشارت نجوان قبل قليل وحلول وهذه المنطقه
باتيه تعرضت لصواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه
التي وصلت الى هناك قبل قليل في قصف نوعي
وصلت الصواريخ صحيح خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه ولكن اليوم ادت هذه الصواريخ الى
اصابات مباشره تحديدا في المنطقه الجنوبيه
من تل ابيب لتكون هذه العمليه قد تدخل
العمليه العسكريه في مسار مختلف اذا
انتقلنا الى قطاع غزه وصوره اقرب الى
القطاع فنحن نتحدث عن محيط قطاع غزه الذي
تحول الى ما يشبه بدائره النار المغلقه
كما اشرنا في اكثر من مناسبه من بدايه من
عسقلان شمالا الى ازديروت في المنطقه
الشماليه الشرقيه الى نتيفوت وصولا الى
مجمع مستوطنات اشكول في المنطقه الجنوبيه
ثلاث محاور مهمه للقصف القصف المق
الفلسطينيه اليوم المناطق الجنوبيه تجمع
مستوطنات اشكول المناطق الشماليه الشرقيه
وما حولها والمناطق الشرقيه عسقلان وما
حولها وزكيم وهنا كما اشرنا يغطي من هنا
يغطي زميلنا الياس كرامي الذي ظهر في اكثر
مناسبه اذا هذه المناطق تحولت الى ما يمكن
قول بانها مناطق فارغه من السكان مناطق
تحولت الى مناطق محظور التجول فيها بفعل
صواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه وشاهدنا ايضا
ان هذه المناطق لا يمكن الاقتراب اكثر من
ذلك نحن نتحدث عن هذه المسافه التي لا
تزيد عن اثنين الى 12 الى 15 كيلو مترا
فقط عن سياج الفاصل بين قطاع غزه والبلدات
والمستوطنات الاسرائيليه اذا انتقلنا الى
صوره اقرب الى هذه المناطق فنحن نتحدث
بدرجه اساسيه عن
كيسوفيم ومجمع مستوطنات اشكول قبل قليل
دورت دورت صافرات الانذار وبطبيعه الحال
ايضا في المنطقه الشماليه دوت صفارات
الانذار ووصلت صواريخ المقاومه الفلسطينيه
الى هذه المناطق لتصل هذه المناطق سيستر
صواريخ المقاومه الى هذه المناطق بكثافه
ناريه عاليه يبدو او كما يقال بانه لم
يسبق خلال ساعات هذه المواجهه ان وصلت
الصواريخ الى هذه المناطق بهذه الكميه
وهذه دقه الاصابات حيث شاهدنا قبل قليل
اصابه منزل بشكل مباشر في مدينه ازديروت
على المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من قطاع غزه
احدى ابرز المستوطنات او المدن او البلدات
الاسرائيليه التي نشاهدها هذه التي
نشاهدها على الشاشه مشاهدينا الكرام لا
تبعد الا كما اشرنا حوالي 12 الى 15 كيلو
مترا فقط من المناطق الشرقيه لوسط قطاع
غزه اذا ما فرغنا هذه الخريطه من الضربات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه للمناطق الاسرائيليه
وانتقلنا الى داخل قطاع غزه الذي ايضا
اليوم
كان مشتعلا منذ الساعات الاولى لهذه
المواجهه واليوم تحديدا كانت مدينه خان
يونس مسرح عمليات القوات الاسرائيليه التي
نفذت بطيرانها وبصواريخها نفذت عمليتي
اغتيال في في مدينه خان يونس احدى هاتين
العمليتين ادت الى استشهاد علي غالي قائد
الوحده الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس الذراع
المسلح لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي وعضو المكتب
العسكري للسرايا وبعد ساعات انطلقت كميه
كبيره من الصواريخ الفلسطينيه من قطاع غزه
باتجاه مستوطنات غلاف غزه ولكن بعد ساعات
ايضا من هذه الصواريخ التي انطلقت من غزه
شهدت خان يونس ايضا عمليه اغتيال اخرى
نفذتها القوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
واستهدفت نائب علي غالي وهو احمد ابو دقه
في شقه سكنيه في ايضا في مدينه خان يونس
ليستشهد اليوم اثنان من قيادات سرايا
القدس ويبلغ مجموع ما اغتيالهم او
استشهادهم في قطاع غزه منذ بدايه هذه
الجوله الى 28 شهيدا منهم خمسه من القاده
العسكريه لسرايا القدس الجناح المسلح
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي لتكون بدرجه اساسيه
اليوم العمليات العسكريه محيط قطاع غزه
التي شاهدناه قبل قليل كما نشاهد محيط
قطاع غزه او ما بيتعرف بمستوطنات غلاف غزه
هي كانت مسرح العمليات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه خان يونس كانت مسرح العمليات
للقوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي التي قتلت
اثنين من قيادات سرايا القدس وبطبيعه
الحال النقطه الابرز والاهم في عمليات
اليوم هي نيتيفول
هذه المدينه الواقعه الى جنوب مدينه لوت
جنوب تل ابيب روحوفت التي سقط فيها قتيل
اسرائيلي ويبدو ان هذه العمليه التي وصلت
الى هذه المنطقه جنوب تل ابيب ستكون محو
عمليات او نقطه تحول فيما بات يعرف في هذه
العمليه العسكريه مع انتظار الاجتماع
الامني الاسرائيلي الذي ينتظر ان او من
المتوقع ان تخرج منه قرارات جديده للقياده
الاسرائيليه السياسيه والامنيه اما بتوسيع
دائره الاغتيالات او التحول الى وقف اطلاق
نار ولكن لا يبدو ان وقف اطلاق النار قريب
وفي الا